what's up y'all this is eric griffin i
want to talk to you about hellofresh
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy fun
and most importantly affordable and
that's why it's america's
number one meal kit
big shout out today to helix sleep take
their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to the mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life
find your perfect mattress at helix
sleep.com
griffin let's start the
[Music]
[Music]
okay hey what's up
welcome back to roofing with griffin no
regular intro today
or maybe i showed the intro that my boy
made
i don't even know i'm winging it new
angle this week
i'm still in new york it's dreary as
hell today
um oscar sunday i
haven't watched one of these so-called
best picture oscar movies
you know i feel like the oscars have
turned into
like the guilt it's like whatever guilty
movie
where people have to suffer this that's
supposed to be entertainment now
like that's supposed to be artistic
right but anyway we'll get into that
but um first just want to say
uh what's up welcome to riffing with
griffin
you know from nyc
ah it's your boy i'm in my hotel rooms
that cheer that they have in the hotel
so uncomfortable
so i'm sitting in this i'm just sitting
on the edge of the bed but even this is
going to be uncomfortable i should just
lay down over here and
do my podcast but this is like a chill
edition of riffing with griffin
so i want to thank everybody uh for
being here
you know um yeah so
i'm back i'm still in new york so last
week's
episode i told a really great story
about you know meeting ray romano for
the first time and going to the comedy
club but i kept saying the wrong comedy
club i kept saying carolines are what i
meant was the
seller the comedy seller that's what i
meant
so you regular listeners who you know
and some people know
they hit me up like did you mean
caroline i thought you performed at
caroline's already yes i have
it's just you know two c names and i was
just really overly excited to tell the
story about
ray romano and shooting this movie
yeah so we went to the cellar actually
last night so
because i you know met with the lady
and she saw me perform or whatever it
was last week so i had
like two paid spots regular spots this
yesterday at this comedy cellar in
new york so i went to the conversation
last night it was like
i went up and then ray went up after me
he wasn't being promoted he was actually
being promoted by the character in the
movie which is funny
because i guess if you put like ray
romano is going to be there you know
then maybe more people will show up than
they want i mean he's just trying to be
chill he hasn't really performed stand
up in a while but the guy's just funny
man
you know he's just funny he just says
things funny
uh it's just interesting to watch uh
he's really
cool dude man i gotta tell you like real
cool down to earth guy
for a guy that was making so much money
at the height of everybody loves raymond
and i mean like the highest paid actor
on television
you know what i mean he was making bank
generational wealth
and he's still here doing it and still
just sort of sort of like a
chill guy you know
he wants to go to the pizza place you
know i mean he wants to walk down the
street he loves to just chat with you
you know he's dressed like a hobo you
know what i mean
i always felt like the richest guys they
just like it's not like he's wearing
louis vuitton or whatever you know he
don't floss
man he's just like a simple dude dude
it's just really refreshing
but i don't know i mean what what
whatever like you know what do they say
i always feel like there's two times two
times
that you see a person's personality
or the worst how about this the worst
parts of their personality come through
some may disagree with the first one i
say when people are drunk
it shows a lot about them themselves
some demons come out
uh when people are drunk but alcohol
affects people in different ways
so i'm not going to say that's exactly
who they are
because i've been challenged on this um
but i will say that it shows
something about them right you got happy
drunks you got
flirty drunks you got anger when
somebody's like an angry
drunk i feel like you know your
inhibitions are down and now this is how
you really feel is coming out and you're
just like you know
violent or whatever it is i don't like
that but the other one which is like
this is really accurate is when people
are rich when people start getting some
fame and success when people start
getting like they
come into a lot of money and all of a
sudden their personality changes
like they don't talk to people they used
to talk to you're like what happened to
you
why are you acting like that or they uh
i see there's a lot of entertainment
business
i have i have people i'm talking about
people at the comedy store i ain't gonna
call out people's names i ain't gonna
put people on blast like that i'm not
trying to like
get into some like you know drama all
right but there's a lot of people at the
comedy store
who all of a sudden became famous
not overnight but they went from like
you're working after all of a sudden
superstardom
and these [ __ ] act different
they're different now funky in the
hallway
there's some people like got really
really famous and all of a sudden
they acting like they don't know you
they just act weird and that's just like
oh you so you're just a dick
this is like you've always wanted to do
this since you're a dick
listen i'm not super famous but you know
when i'm walking down the street
i know when somebody knows me when
they're like hey montez you know
especially at the height of workaholics
i still was never
i never liked to be like oh cuckoo cool
you know hey
i do take advantage of the privileges i
like stuff and i like
i'm bougie you know i like to upgrade
when i'm on a plane i like the best room
in a hotel that i can afford right
i like certain luxuries but when it
comes to just interacting with regular
folks i try to be
pretty chill pretty pretty much the same
person i don't let the fame and fortune
whatever try to try to get to me
but it's not even i have a lot of that
but i it's enough
especially at certain places like if i
go to vegas
being in vegas that's like that age
group people that go to vegas work
holics fans you know
they see me at the table hey you know
whoa my god what are you doing here
i don't like to notice it my friends
notice it more than i do
got a buddy of mine we'll be at a
restaurant and when it first really
started happening big and he'd be the
first one to be like yo man that table
over there they know who you are
and i would just kind of be like you
know what let's just i don't care
because you know why i didn't want to
care i really don't really think about
it too much
it's because i don't want to miss it
when it's gone because it goes
i got a lot of friends of mine i've been
in the business a long time now i've
seen
people they get on sitcoms things have
started going they were like on cartoons
everything was going like oh
and then it just all went away and they
miss it
i could see it on their faces that's how
jealousy comes up into play
envy you can't be like that like i've
been in the business long enough now to
see
people who were coming up past me or
people who are coming up get like
equivalent success or
even a little bit more but you know and
then you have to look at them and be
like yo good for you
you know um we were in the hallway at
the same time
you know we were like you know you know
you know someone is like that chris redd
chris redd i remember when he first came
to la and he was just like talking about
you know being broke and you know just
trying to like make it into business and
then now he's like on
snl a star bona fide star on another
sitcom always working
movies to do works and i'm like super
proud of him you know
as somebody that i was older than him
but i've seen him he's surpassed me
and i'm but i'm i'm like good for you
i'm super supportive of the guy
so you know you have that that kind of
stuff happens so you see that in the
business so
that's why you have to keep an even keel
you got to keep your wits about you you
got to
keep your personality intact so you
could still be like cool with people
when you see them
it's tough it's a tough you know it's an
ego check
you know your ego gets challenged all
the time
in this business especially in the
comedy business because it's like you
know you're
you know you'll be like on a lineup at a
certain spot
and maybe you're in that spot because of
what you're currently doing what's
happening in your life for
even previous accomplishments right
and then you know here comes the young
whippersnapper who comes up
and you see him and you have like a
certain hierarchy and then all of a
sudden out of nowhere you don't even
know when it happened
this dude's taking your spot or he's
right there with you
and then you're just kind of like oh
what's going on that could be
challenging to the
comedian's ego especially when you've
been doing it for a long time because
this is like
it's a leader board right like you're
playing golf or something and sometimes
people are going to be doing better or
they can do it equivalent and they come
they come out of nowhere they're playing
against the course the course of
entertainment business
so you just got to be prepared for that
i don't even know why i went on this
rant
i've been doing like a lot of stream of
consciousness type stuff when i'm doing
my podcast recently but
anyways oh i remember now i'm just
saying
ray romano is just a kind of dude that
feels
very chilling a humble guy
he's got a good balance of like we went
to nobu
he's gonna go hey let's go to nobu you
know and um
he took us to noble me the his partner
and the dp we were sitting in nobu you
know and he's like what do you want to
order and he's just
ordering a bunch of stuff you know 800
bill it's nothing pulls out his gold
card boom
it's on me that type of thing but at the
same time he's like let's go to the
pizza place and we're walking down the
street getting pizza and he's just
yip yapping like a normal guy
i don't know like why we say that i
don't know why we say that like when
we're around super rich successful
people
why it's important to us for them to
like be just like us
but at the same time it's like they
don't got to be just like us they're
like they're not
their life's different they had a
different path
and if you're super successful you
should be able to enjoy your super
success
so it's really just about like a
person's personality how they deal
how they function in that world
you know some people feel guilty with a
lot of success
or some people are afraid of success so
they don't want to achieve it
but there's no right or wrong way to act
i mean it's just a common sense approach
of like
are you a decent person are you
relatable
you know and this is why someone like
that can become successful on a sitcom
called
everybody loves raymond um about a
family guy
you know and then how you you know
that's why i was he
he embodies that guy it was his act you
know he's talking about he's got twins
he's got you know
this this it was based off him so
it's not surprising it's someone like
that so when i watch him do stand-up
you know it's like his phrasing the way
he puts words together
is just funny it's about a sitcom rant
for
10 years or whatever it was and it's
still on the air now in syndication so
kudos to him the movie's going well um
i've been posting like these weird
pictures of myself in the in the outfits
i'm playing like an outrageous character
i feel like the comic relief and a
really
dramatic you know dramedy type movie
but i'm watching these scenes play out
and there was this really
great scene that i i get to witness
that's happening at a wedding scene you
know
and i got to tell you it was written by
ray and his buddy mark
who worked on his show um men of a
certain age that was on tnt
uh anyway so they've been working on
this movie for six years and
it's just a really powerful scene and i
just find myself missing my cues i'm
supposed to stand up at a certain time
but i found myself a few times
just watching it play out being like wow
this is really great
so i'm not just saying that because i'm
in the movie i'm telling you this is
when this movie finally comes out
whatever the title of it's going to be
you really got to check it out it's
really like when somebody's
passion project and they finally get it
off the ground
it's good to see so this is a good uh
ray romano project so yeah
you know i went to the seller um
the first time i did it i was nervous
but this time it was chill i was cool
just pop just right back in my element
it's a magical room it really does
remind me of the or
in la at the comedy store there's just
something about like the configuration
or something about like
the essence of comedy that's in the room
that has
so many greats have been in there and so
many you know it was cool
i saw um
louie was
at there you know
and he did comedy
and i watched him um
louis louis c.k you know
you know he's the embattled comedian
with all the
controversy and uh you know misconduct
behavior and you know he got cancelled
so he's you know i don't think somebody
should be canceled forever
at a certain point i mean even our
justice system doesn't work like that
you know you go to prison and you
do your time and then you get out and
you're supposed to be you've done your
time
so i don't know i'm not speaking on
whether he should
be able to do his craft or not that's
not for me to say
but i do know i could tell that it's
more difficult for him because whatever
whatever like car blanche he had before
to get away with
saying whatever he wanted to say there's
something
missing from that now that he has to
rebuild
you could tell you know he's got to
rebuild that
that you know equity
like i have to rebuild this so i can
make a point
you know it's hard to when when you're a
kind of comedian that puts things
together
controversially you know and talking
about certain hot topics and you're
bringing them up to make this overall
point to make everybody think
it's hard to do that when people go well
i don't know
if you're allowed to talk about this
kind of stuff anymore
i i believe when i'm watching him that
he's lost some of that equity
he's lost some of that uh where people
okay we forgive him for saying this
certain words certain phrases
certain things he's talking about where
before would be like okay well he's
going someplace let's see where he's
going
so now people are like you could you
have a feeling of like well i don't know
oh no you know what i mean maybe i'm
overthinking it because i'm a comic
because but just watching i've i
just felt that sort of vibe but you know
it is what it is it is what it is
uh you know they don't let you record so
nobody's recording and stuff which is
good i mean i
i think that like you guys don't
understand that when you're a comic and
you're
working out your act it's not great or
you might say some things that are just
not
you know appropriate especially in these
sensitive cancer culture times
but in that process of trying to figure
that joke out
over time then you're going to get it to
a place where it's like okay this is
acceptable for society i guess is the
the term or it you know it falls within
the range of like this is super
inappropriate and offensive
to over here where it's like just
you know it's so vanilla nothing's
happening you want to be someplace there
where even the people that get offended
by everything can go okay i understand
what you're saying
all right you know you want to find that
balance
so you need the time to go do that in
front of a crowd
you know i don't understand what people
don't get that you got to be able to
talk in front of a crowd you got to be
able to work it out you got to hear when
people laugh and don't laugh you got to
be like ooh that didn't work the way i
thought it was going to work you got it
and it has to be done in front of a
crowd we can't do that in front of a
mirror by ourselves
we need feedback so the way
the way people you know they're ready to
like record and be like i can't believe
you said this and they put it on the
internet for what for your fame
what for what sucks
it sucks that we can't just have an
experience
can we just experience this in the now
and that be it and move on from it
for live performance you know like this
happened here it doesn't need to be
shared
it doesn't need to be captured in a time
capsule to be replayed over and over and
over again
sometimes can we just share this moment
right now and it'd be nothing else
it's tough in this day and age with the
way technology is but
you know it is what it is more power to
the guy
um again me supporting
uh a comic working through his demons
does not mean i condone any
person's behavior because that's that
that's that's the jump people make you
know
it's like you mentioned someone and then
people translate that into what they
want it to mean
oh well because you said this it means
you
you know a b and c and it's like that's
not true don't speak for me
um and that's your own personal opinion
i don't care
you know i'm really tired of the fact
that we have to like pretend like we
care what cancer culture people think
it's like who cares i'm glad you have
that opinion that's your opinion
the fact the fact that we weaponize that
is what's the problem
everybody should have their opinion you
don't like something great
but don't make your opinion fact you you
know you're speaking for someone well
because that person said that
he's now racist this that that it's like
no that's just what you
think
we gotta we just really gotta work on
that but
i don't know who knows right
i don't know about um if new york
cares about health and safety
but it's just it's just a dog and pony
show though i feel like
i'll give you exactly like forget about
new york for a second let's just talk
about
you guys don't know what's going on on
sets right now with the covet
restrictions
it's crazy even when i filmed the pilot
bucktown
you know there's this whole thing you
know they have these zones you know
first of all we're tested three times a
week
three times a week every two days you
have to get a covet test
all right i'm vaccinated most people are
make sure you check out my my
vaccination videos on my patreon if you
want to be a patreon member
eric patreon.com eric griffin but
most peop you know so anyway you get you
get vaccinated all right
not vaccinated you get you get tested
three times a week so by the time it's
time to shoot
you've been tested a couple of times now
you're
you're in the clear you know so you're
on set and they have these different
zones you know so the actors are zone a
let's say then they have other people
who are zone b and they're not supposed
to be around zone
so they got all these weird-ass
restrictions right
everybody's wearing a mask and a face
covering and it's like and that's the
part that gets me
to me it should be all right we're clear
is everybody clear everybody's tested
especially now
who's vaccinated all right why are we
wearing a mask
it's so let me tell you something it's
so uncomfortable
it's so like you it's always present on
your mind you're just like
mass i can't i can't i feel restricted
you know
on a set you're an actor you're trying
to like get into the thing you got the
stupid mask and then there's like these
mask gustapo who are on the set too with
these
idiotic sag restrictions right so
they're there right there
can you put your mask on i need you to
put your hands up oh
it's like set cairns you know and
they're just always
like you pull your mask down for a
second until like you know you're
scratching your face or whatever they're
hey i need you to put your mask on
and they hate their job you can tell
they don't want to be those people
they need to find people up it's like
this is like meter maids you know
so you got but here's the part that
kills me all right this is like this is
a dog and pony show if it'll be like to
pretend like
they care about health and safety
because once you say action
oh we're about to shoot the scene you
take your mask off all the extras
everybody's taking their mask off
all the actors and performers their
masks are off three four minute scene
what do you think covet is like oh
they're they're shooting let me just
i'm gonna wait over here till they
finish shooting and then i'll try to
attack them when they put their masks on
like what are we doing what are we doing
everybody's tested
everybody's vaccinated what are we doing
and and if you're gonna tell me well you
could still pass the okay
then we shouldn't be shooting at all but
if we're going to be shooting
we're making an agreement we're saying
all right
i've done all i need to do i'm being
tested three times a week i've got my
vaccination
i'm willing to go on set and risk the
chance that's what i'm saying by taking
the job and working
i'm saying i'm okay if something happens
i i'm okay with that
but this dog and pony show of like them
trying to pretend like they care about
health and safety
is ridiculous it's ridiculous
it's like when you go to a restaurant
the whole [ __ ] is ridiculous you know
i've talked about this before but it's
like oh when you walk in please take
care
hold on your mass who's that for who's
that for
right and then as soon as you sit down
at a table four feet away oh you could
take it off
now you're in the safety zone there's no
safety zone
if you're one of these people who are
like always talking about masks and you
go to restaurants
you need to shut the [ __ ] up okay i i
don't want to hear you
because what are you talking about you
think that the
disease stops at a table no
you're just saying to yourself i'm sick
of this and i need to eat i want to eat
i want to have my mask off
sebastian and i sebastian maniscalco
we've been hanging out it was been great
you know every night we went to dinner
after after the shoot and it was good
catching up with him and just laughing
we just we laughed a lot we had a really
great time
walking around at these different
restaurants it was just fun times with
him so
kudos to him but we went to this one
restaurant right
and we're sitting outside on an
uncomfortable s
table with a picnic table like you know
this bougie fancy italian restaurant
and they have these restrictions so they
come over like can you fill this out for
contact tracing
you're like what okay all right
you know what i mean i think it's
ridiculous but okay i get it just in
case right
and then it's like when the waiter comes
to the table can you please put your
mask on
it's like [ __ ] you man what
we're outside cold ass weather and you
gotta sit in here
and every time the dude comes over um
can you like what
it's like overboard like never going to
that restaurant again if i'm in new york
because who wants to put up with that
it's like you're you're mid-eating you
know you're cutting your food and okay i
gotta put this down and
put it okay uh is everything okay yeah
[ __ ] everything's okay get away from
the [ __ ] table dude
one of the like one of the just waitress
comes by and gives us water
and she's obviously she didn't even say
anything right now i knew i was like
what's going on here you what do you
think about this she was like i hate it
it's just one of those things where it's
like the owner of that place
is one of these people who are like i
still want to make money
i still want to make money at my super
expensive fancy place and then i want to
have the perception
that i care about health and safety
as long as there are people sitting in a
room because there's people inside too
by the way
as long as people are inside and they
have their masks
off a majority of the room has their
masks off while they're eating their
food
don't tell me you care about health and
safety because when somebody walks over
to the table
all of a sudden now putting the mask on
at this point
is going to make a difference that much
of a difference is what i'm saying
new york but in new york's bananas they
got people
you know eating on sidewalks right just
like you know hundreds of people walking
by
and like now when i'm sitting at this
table with my mask off
all of a sudden i'm pretending like
somehow i'm safe
but then there's people just walking by
i don't know what we're doing
listen i'm all for health and safety but
i'm not all for like people pretending
like they're for health and safety
it's all for for optics this dog and
pony show that's going on
everywhere
what's up guys i'm here to talk to you
about my new sponsor hello fresh
you get fresh pre-measured ingredients
and mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door
you know what i love about this kind of
thing is you know when you want to cook
something you want to say have a recipe
you want to cook something and it takes
onions when you go to the store you
don't buy one onion you end up buying
you have to buy three of this
four of that and then to make one meal
you have
enough to make six meals but you don't
necessarily need those ingredients for
those meals
that's why you get this because it's
pre-measured
so if you need one onion there's only
gonna be one onion in there and that's
the best thing about
getting these sort of meal services
hellofresh cuts out stressful meal
planning and grocery store trips exactly
what i'm saying
so you can enjoy cooking and get dinner
on the table in about 30 minutes or less
it's fun it's stress-free it's actually
a nice hobby when you cook for yourself
and you feel better about the food and
the meal so i highly recommend it
hellofresh offers 25 plus recipes to
choose from each week from vegetarian
meals
to craft burgers and extra special
gourmet options
there's something for everyone to enjoy
like if you have allergies
you know you you set it up you what you
want like say if you're vegan or if
you're like
you have a dairy allergy or you have a
nut allergy they
you don't even have to worry about it
because you put all that stuff in and
they send you exactly what you need to
make a perfect
meal so i really do highly recommend it
all right
get better value hellofresh is 20
cheaper than shopping at your local
grocery store and
72 percent cheaper than restaurant meals
without
sacrificing the quality that's the best
part about that all right so go
go to hellofresh.com 12
griffin that's one two griffin 12
griffin and use code 12 griffin
for 12 free meals including
free shipping wow did you hear that
that's hellofresh.com 12 griffin and use
code 12 griffin
for 12 free meals including free
shipping damn it's a good ass deal
so you guys go to that website right now
let me say it again
hellofresh.com slash 12
one two griffin and use code 12 griffin
for 12 free meals
including free shipping
hello fresh let's get back to the show
ugh am i anti-master
i am i think i hate it
i get it i do it i have plenty of them i
wear it
you know i'm not trying to be i'm not
gonna be a person on a plane like you
know with my mask off like
you don't tell me what to do you know
i'm not that person
but i could complain about it it's my
brand i complain
i get a lot of [ __ ] that complain
about my complaining you're a [ __ ]
i just want you to know anytime you come
to my
page and you complain about me
complaining
you're a [ __ ] okay you're doing exactly
what i'm doing
if you're at home like this guy
complains too much let me go on his
instagram
yo man stop complaining you're
complaining [ __ ]
shut up this is my brand
you come to me because i complain about
stuff that's my comedy that's who i
am and i'm i own it you own it [ __ ]
yeah you when you're writing right now
oh and i know i'm getting to you because
you're like oh
if i say something now i'm a [ __ ] but i
gotta say something because
i don't want him to think he got to me
so now you're in a quandary right now
are you gonna put your comment
are you gonna put your message huh [ __ ]
go ahead
put your message put your comment right
now go ahead
show me how you're a [ __ ] prove to me
you're a [ __ ]
guys when you see a comment of somebody
bitching about my complaining
just hashtag hey you're a [ __ ] just put
it right there for them so they know
so they know that they're the ones okay
because i'm owning this [ __ ] right now
i own it i have a thing called bitching
with griffin this is this part right now
i'm bitching about the people bitching
about me bitching you a [ __ ]
what's up y'all i'm here to talk about
helix sleep look i'm in this hotel i'm
on this terrible ass
mattress okay i miss my helix sleep
mattress y'all everybody's unique and
helix knows that so they have several
different mattresses types
so the big thing about them is they have
this two-minute sleep quiz you take the
quiz you tell them how you sleep
you like it soft hard medium side
stomach
back body type style and they match you
to the mattress that best suits you i
got a great one at home and i can't wait
to get back to it helix is awesome
but you don't need to take my word for
it helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020
and by gq and wired magazine now i need
you guys to go to helixleak.com
griffin helixsleep.com griffin
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to the customized
mattress i keep saying that because it's
the most important thing about that
getting a customized mattress so i want
you to do that
they have a 10-year warranty and you'll
get it you'll get to try it out for a
hundred nights for free
they'll ship it for free they'll come
pick it up for free if you don't like it
but i know you're gonna like it helix is
offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helixsleep.com
griffin get there helixsleep.com
griffin and have the best sleep of your
life
so i don't like wearing masks is it okay
nobody likes wearing masks you wear the
mask because you think it's helping you
because it's protecting you you think
you're protecting others oh that's
another thing too
like when you're on a set so i'm wearing
a mask to protect other people
i'm the one that has to test three times
a week i'm the one that has to test i'm
the one that they
did they meant to make sure are you
vaccinated okay so the actor
we're good we don't need to protect you
it's the all the other people on set
they wear masks
the camera guy the whoever right but
we're
we're the ones that had to go through
all this rigmarole to make sure that
we're good and we're safe we're ready to
go there's no covet in our body
we test it three times a week why the
[ __ ] am i wearing a mask
what am i wearing a mask for all you're
doing is making actors uncomfortable
okay i'm bitching
now you know what i hear it that's
enough
i made my point it's just i'm just you
know what can i vent on my podcast this
eventing with griff
it's just annoying it's annoying to me
because the moment they say action and
we have to take our masks off
is this when like how are we safe right
now
so no we're making an agreement that at
this moment right now
we're saying someone could get it or not
get it and we're okay with that because
we need to finish this job which creates
money and you know what i mean so at
that point you don't really care about
health and safety so stop with the dog
and pony show
it's just you know it's
just super frustrating man
all right
what else is going on i don't even know
what's going on
i want to do my spoiler alerts for uh
i want to do it i usually like to do it
at the end but i saw the
finale of falcon and winter soldier and
i was a little disappointed so spoiler
alert
actually i won't go into too much detail
about what was happening in the episode
but i don't know
i um it was
you know it's like you got to have a
final fight you got to build up to like
this is what's happening and then they
sort of like teased that this is going
to continue to go on you find out who
the villain is
i won't say some secret villain the
power broker you find out who that is
and um i will say that again um
i did i did feel like it was real cheesy
right
there was like some cheesy moments like
when the falcons new suit and he's got
the
captain america shield and when he and
you know because bucky
went to he got he asked the wakandans to
do him a favor so he wanted because the
falcon
outfit got messed up so he's like yo can
you make a new falcon outfit for the him
and you know he did he asked that favor
and they made this
because wakana could do anything
apparently you know so when he lands
with the with the new look suit with the
thing
i had a little moment of like yeah you
know what i mean
and it was like you know this they still
got this sort of like racial thing going
on you know
uh kind of addressing the racial divide
in the country
even within this show that they had
probably made previously but it's
something that's always present it's
ever present
you know um
[Music]
yeah it was uh
it was good you know i mean it was good
but again there's some cheesy moments
but it's like it's you know what it's
the hardest thing to do is to finish
something so the build-up to it is the
best part
then they don't always achieve but this
is like an ongoing open-ended
story like these guys are not going
anywhere you know
you know and i think that they overall
did a good job and so i don't want to
spoil too much
so i'm not even going to talk about it
further than that but
you know you're going to watch it i
think you should watch it you know i
think it's a decent enough
ending to this little short mini series
and for me it's like i hope it continues
like i hope they just keep making these
shows you know i hope this show
continues i hope they don't stop it
i mean i hope that they convince like
the bigger actors
in the avengers universe in the avengers
mcu to like come like it would have been
dope if thor made an appearance
because at a certain point at a certain
point you can't
have some major thing happen in the mcu
universe on this television show
and because we're going to be like you
know where's a hulk
you know what i mean we're black widow
at or or whoever's still alive now i
don't even know black there black
widow's dead but
is she dead i don't know you know
where's where's everybody
in the world so the low-key one is
coming next loki and i saw the preview
for that and i really like it
i really like this whole thing about
there's like a
time cops and all that kind of stuff uh
time bureau that is like keeping track
and making sure that
the universe is you know on on point and
loki's messing it up so
i really like and that guy that plays
loki is a great actor
so i'm looking forward to that series so
disney plus he came through it took you
too long
it took you too long and i hope that
there's not just like big gaps in
between the series
and stuff that they do but this is great
i think they're doing a great job with
uh
the marvel universe portion of disney
plus so
that's my short thing all right so what
should we uh you know i guess
you're probably wondering why haven't
you talked about this but so let's talk
about the major major major news from
the past week is
you know the george floyd the siobhan
case the the officer that murdered
george floyd
you know he was found guilty
my first thought is you know
i guess i i've taken a week now to
really think about it
just to build up to it is like i was
nervous because
i was alive i was living in los angeles
when the rodney king verdict
came through about those officers and
there was videotape footage
they beat the [ __ ] out of rodney king
like when you look back at that video
what how what that use of force
is ever necessary if you think about it
right now like if that case was being
tried today with that video footage
with those guys being let off now
with the consciousness of america with
all the white guilt that has been
galvanized and
and uh you know like all the young
people who are now like yeah
you know we're going to be the
generation that does it right you know
which i'm not mocking it i'm just saying
it's just
you you've been pushed into it because
you had to be pushed into it
and so sometimes it's taken too far like
you know
the wokeness is taken to the point of
annoyance but that's what's necessary i
guess to make change
but when you look back i remember the
rodney king beating and everything to
build up in the trial
and then when these guys were found
innocent or you know or not guilty
my god the place went crazy and right
rightly so i mean it was just like a
explosion of
you know i don't condone the actions
that were taken
they were pulling people up pulling
white people out of trucks and beating
them down and peeing on people and
killing people and burning down business
it was just a mess but
you you understood why you understood
that
there was no other outlet what recourse
do people have
when you could beat a dude you could
take a dude out of his car
and viciously beat him get captured on
video
and then through a government trial they
say this person
the people that did this are not they
they're not guilty
what other course do you have you you
have
no there's no outlet other than this
violent destruction
you know that's how people thought at
the time you know what i mean that's i
think that's the feeling when these when
you see looting and writing and that
kind of stuff
i don't like it i think it's ridiculous
i don't think it does any
i don't think it does really any
sometimes the result might be some
positive action
but i feel like it could have been done
a different way but i'm not arguing that
right now
my point i'm trying to make is i was
nervous for this trial
and i think a lot of people were nervous
you know
i was reading some of the things about
what the defense was saying and i was
like wow
is that really the defense you're trying
to take and then he was trying to go for
a mistrial
and then stupid maxine waters running
her lip
thinking she's helping get you know
i don't know if it's true or not in
terms of because the judge himself the
judge himself says well she's giving you
a you know
out giving you a you know for this
verdict to be overturned later
because of her inciting you know and
then the judge not sequestering this
jury and the judge telling them hey
don't watch the news y'all i trust that
this jury
is not going to watch the news so
but to me it was like that's terrible
to think that like it could be
overturned from these sort of
technicalities
that video that eight minute video of
him murdering this dude
that's not enough like you think that
that should overturn anything that
anybody would say
you know but that that's our government
that's
that that's the the judicial system
checks and balances and whatever you
know the laws for mistrials and appeals
and
everything that goes with that is a
strange um
process so let's hope and then and then
there's also the sentencing
like who knows you know according to in
minnesota i heard
you know people spend they do two-thirds
of their
um jail sentence anyway i mean this guy
could be out of prison in 12 years
is that enough time for what he did who
knows you know what i mean so
it's not done yet but my point is
on the heels of that i was worried i was
like oh man what if he i'm here in new
york i'm like what if this dude has
found
if he's found not guilty i mean there
would be
just riots in the streets like people
would just be like no
like you clearly don't care about black
people like that would really be the
message
that somebody can do that
thankfully though
they found him guilty and quick because
that was another thing too
if the jury was in there deliberating
for more than a day i'd be like what are
you guys
what like it seems to like i don't know
care who you are even if you are
a clan member and you hate black people
with your soul and you
saw that tape even you would
even if you had even oh and they they
caught him killing him
that's what that should still be your
thought process
even if you feel like this oh he's he's
supposed to do that because we those
people aren't real whatever
they don't deserve whatever you think
you still know
this is this is a murder that's what i'm
saying
so for that jury to be deliberating for
more than any time that they needed to
deliberate
i thought that was a good sign too
because i even thought i thought even
that would cause
trouble i thought if they were
deliberating for more than a day even
that would make people like
they'd be protesting rising up like what
are you doing in there
so they went in it was quick boom boom
boom guilty on all charges
i mean to have that kind of video
footage video footage of the eight
minutes
eight minutes
so there it is
but now there's this sort of like you
got what you wanted
but it's like did we get what we want
you know what i mean
um i don't know
but i gotta return this text
i know i'm doing everything like this is
like live i'm not even gonna edit this
part out
um
the um you know so it's like
now there's like this sort of feeling
that people have
of like okay so what's next you know
like
like what's next like people are
celebrating it's like damn that's how
bad it is but you have to celebrate
something so clearly seems to be open to
shut case
i don't even know why i even went to
trial i mean it's a weird thing for this
guy to come you know
but i get it you know who wants to admit
what what they did they're not going to
do that
you know it's like it's like it is what
it is i'm surprised he didn't try to
take a a
a deal maybe their deal was offered you
know this amount of jail time
but the pros but you know the defense
prosecution was like nah nah
we got to open a shut case we're going
to court so
who knows man who knows but then you had
this other case now
where i don't know what the girl's name
is i should have researched it but the
stream of consciousness you know
the 16 year old girl she got a knife she
about to stab another girl
to cop shot the girl then immediately
it was uproar again like if this this
was if this was the same thing
lebron james tweets out something he
takes it down because it's you know
it's it started to you make hate and the
people that hate lebron james and what
he does
they use it they're using it as a way to
attack him you know
but you know he had he had the balls
enough to be like you know what
i got to take this down put up another
statement then even the police put up a
statement on him
saying like yo man you need to get all
the facts straight before you
gaslight people with this like rhetoric
you know because that is what it is
like every it's case by case okay it's
like
not every time like if we want to talk
about the police force
and their use of force or their
techniques
in these situations let's talk about
that
but not it's not every time that they
have to use force
that it's racial
that's hard for people to understand
especially coming off the heels of what
we just saw
but what are you supposed to do what are
you supposed to like what is this person
supposed to do
it's like tasing they say well shoot him
in the leg that's all the things people
say is if people got that kind of aim
that kind of training what this guy
trained marksman in the moment this cop
sees this happening is he thinking to
himself well let me this ain't a movie
you know let me shoot him an ankle and
make sure this i mean it's just not
i don't know if they're that that
properly trained in the first place
like if if the problem you you want to
say is the cops need better training
and then in a situation they're showing
that they're not trained to the level of
a green beret
then you want to say you want to tell
them what they should have done in that
situation
it's a tragedy that someone is now dead
a young woman is dead her family is
mourning
my condolences go out to them you know
but this is just one of these situations
where we have to just take a minute
assess everything before we put it in
the same category as george floyd
i guess i want to finish off by talking
about this is my problem like you know
so now they got this gun control stuff
that they're talking about biden's
trying to push through
it's just about background checks i
don't understand why that's such a big
deal
i don't understand why that's such a big
deal like let's do an extensive
background check before somebody gets a
lethal weapon
okay is that how is that such a bad
thing
why is that you know what what rights
and freedoms are being taken away by by
being like
yeah can we make sure that the person
that gets this isn't somebody that's
going to end up killing people
let's try our best even if we fail let's
just do our part
but here's my thing we're fighting the
left the right progressive liberals
conservatives
fight about guns do you know who's
laughing
the gun companies the gun manufacturers
because my question to them is
why are you still making lethal force
weapons lethal weapons
where's the [ __ ] where's the where's
the phase guns
where's the the sleep guns and the
freeze guns and why is the taser
technology still
stupid why are they still shooting like
two
why are they shot like that where's the
like where's like like the
instant freeze serum or something like
darts that go into people that make them
like you know where's that stuff
where's why haven't we upgraded
the weaponry you know where's the
phasers on stun man
i think gun technology reminds me of
electric car technology 25 years ago
like there was that documentary what
happened to electric cars
this reminds me of that so much it's
like they made these [ __ ] electric
cars the gas companies were like nope
nope
nope nope and then they made them look
stupid nobody wanted to buy them
they just it just got it got put aside
through greed corruption and now look at
us now
i got an electric car there's so many
great looking electric cars now it's
like now it's in the collective
consciousness we're like no no we want
electric cars man
so now they're making them i think that
the gun companies are doing the same
thing to this technology
where is this technology is it out there
can somebody put stuff in the comments
give me some links
are there different types of weapons and
guns and things that
that that the police could be using like
the police should be like they get to a
scene of a domestic violence
they should be able to just you know
they just shoot everybody
everybody's like you know they're like
all right let's now we can find out what
happened
you know about something if you're so
trigger happy give them
guns that don't kill why does it have to
be lethal force
why are we still shooting little pieces
of metal
at people to stop them is that
we can go to we could send [ __ ] we got a
space station circling the the globe
right now
my phone can listen to a song and tell
me
who the author is and the lyrics you
know your phone
like you know what's scary you know have
you guys ever thought about this
let's say you put up a post on instagram
right now
let's say you put up a post and in your
post you say hey guys i just got my
vaccine
even if you don't put any words even if
you just say
my mood today is the title but you say
the words
i got my vaccine today all of a sudden
instagram
puts a little link up that says
something about
you know vaccine covert vaccine
information
on your video how the hell do they know
like the algorithm or something is
listening for the words
covet and vaccine and i got my vaccine
like it's
listening to what we're saying and it's
putting links up
for us without our consent so your phone
is doing
way more than you think dude here's
another one i want you guys to do this
i want you guys to do this uh you go to
like
your um your phone okay so go to your
phone
and go to like for you okay
um oh where is it's so hard to like oh
here we go
damn i found it it's like it's like such
a hard
way to find it oh here we go here we go
so go to search on you go to your if you
have an iphone
go to search right go to search right
now and your pictures area i'm saying
so go to your iphotos go to the bottom
on the menu and go to search
and then go to this thing called
categories
and look at these categories man the
categories
i didn't put these categories the phone
is looking at your picture
and figuring out what you're doing like
sunbathing i looked at it and i was like
oh [ __ ] these are pictures i've taken
while i'm laying
out in the sun or pictures i've taken of
people where the sudden they're laying
on a
a beach or something it goes sunbathing
i was like
when the hell did that become a thing
fireworks if you take pictures of
fireworks it goes under a category
fireworks
basketball i gotta take pictures at the
clipper game and it shows it right there
basketball i was like oh [ __ ]
this phone is doing some uh it it's like
categorizing
my stuff without i didn't even know that
it did that
so this is the level of technology that
we got going on
even at the palm of our fingertips you
know
um just all of the technology we have in
the world right now we're still
shooting little pieces of metal at
people
i don't understand i feel like this
the the weapon technology is being
suppressed
and i don't know why i think
this is the thing that we should be
fighting for let's stop fighting with
each other about
should we have guns or we shouldn't have
guns because by the way gun nuts
those guys those people are all about
gun safety you ever really talked to a
gun nut they got your guns locked
up they know how to clean them they know
where they should go they think you you
people fighting for that
we're not talking about you you're good
you understand gun safety it's like
we're talking about people who casually
get guns and then they don't know how to
use them that well and then they think
they know and then they're using them in
a
you know something's going on with them
and they crack and they want to use
their gun at the post office
they want to you know like all the gun
accidents that have happened where
people aren't taking care of them
they're not
using proper gun safety but and we're
always fighting back and forth i think
it's getting lost in this
that we need to
make better weapons that are
non-lethal right
all right guys i don't want to rant
anymore so that's going to be
uh this week's episode of riffing with
griffin from new york i'll be back
in l.a back in the riffin with griffin
studios next week
i tried the game but my gaming just it's
so hard with just shitty hotel internet
but please still check me out on eric
griffin gaming on twitch eric griffin
gaming
uh appreciate you guys for watching as
always again i'm starting to put up some
patreon content so if you want to go
there i got like five patreon numbers so
man that's you know
it is what it is man i get it but if you
want to support me and i'm trying to put
out more content
go there people have been hitting me up
about a lot of things about hey man can
you review this show can you review this
movie
i'm to try to get to those kinds of
things too and then put that stuff up
either as a bonus content or even on the
patreon i don't know
we're still working it out and i got my
guidance helping me out with these
videos you guys he puts these funny
edits together so i have a video up now
about when i went to go get my
second vaccine shot it's long video it
was 20 minutes
it might be too long it might be boring
but there's some fun stuff in there so
you might want to check that out
um but once again uh this is uh you know
riffing with griffin
uh i appreciate you being here live from
my hotel room in new york
i tried my best to you know i've set it
up as best i can i'm a one-man show
but thanks for watching and i will see
you
next week
you